how did you come to discover your why
then
so I um it was I reached a point in my
career where I had fallen out of love
with my work
um superficially my my life was good you
know I owned my own business we had
amazing clients we did amazing work
doing what was I had a marketing
consultancy yeah
um in New York and uh
I didn't want to wake up at noon anymore
I just was I was done I was a certain
realization of a darling one I mean
you know these things always feel sudden
but they've been you know that's a slow
boiling frog Until you realize the
water's boiling
um so the answer is who knows it it
showed up you know like how long does it
take to feel depressed I you know I
don't know
um and I was deeply embarrassed
feeling bad because I shouldn't look
look what I'm doing look at the things
I'm getting to do
like I shouldn't be you know depressed
or you know not want to go to work and
so I kept it all those negative feelings
to myself
which really is stupid
um and the feelings got darker and
darker and darker and they feed on each
they feed on themselves
and that's the problem with keeping
negative feelings to yourself they they
fester and grow and it got to the point
where I was in really a dark place
but all of my energy went into
pretending that I was happier more in
control and more successful than I
really felt so nobody knew
um and it wasn't until a very dear
friend of mine came to me and said
there's something wrong there's
something different I don't know what it
is but something's off and I
for whatever reason I I opened up and
came clean
and it was cathartic you know it was a
weight lifted off my shoulders and all
of that energy that went into lying
hiding and faking every day
I now had new energy Renewed Energy to
actually find a solution
um uh I'll just spare you the long drawn
out story but I had already articulated
this idea of the why and the Golden
Circle to explain why some marketing
worked and some marketing didn't and it
was the discovery of the human brain the
limbic brain and the neocortex
um uh which I learned at a dinner party
I was sitting next to somebody who their
dad was a neuroscientist I mean it was
just like polite conversation and like
Belle started going off and I realized
it didn't explain why marketing worked
it just it explained why people do what
they do and I realized this was my
problem I knew what I did I knew how I
did it but I couldn't tell you why
that's what I needed to find and I
couldn't do it for myself and so I
brought in an outsider who had
objectivity and took me through some
sort of version of his his process and
mine
um that really helped but the more
important thing was I figured out how to
help my friends find their why sure and
that's what I started doing I started
helping my friends find their why but
there's an element of your story that
and thank you for sharing it that I
think takes courage to do that whether
it was that friend of yours that has
just spotted that something is off
with you to ask you that the courage to
open up and be honest and be vulnerable
with them is something that I think it
doesn't get referred to enough
thank you but I disagree
because I think my friend had the
courage not me
you know
um
I think it's really hard when your
friends say to you there's something
wrong and you go no everything's fine
and then they let it go
or they're not even willing to say some
things off they just kind of it's too
uncomfortable you know we don't like
discomfort discomfort we certainly don't
like causing discomfort and we certainly
don't want to create tension or a fight
and so we just leave it
and I think the courageous friends the
friends who truly truly truly love you
are the ones who will lean into that
tension and go I don't care what you say
and I know you're lying to me
I love you to death and I know
something's wrong and I'm going to keep
asking you until you tell me
you know and more importantly whatever
it is
I got you
I love you
you're safe I don't know what it is and
I don't care what it is just know that
I'm your partner and you are never alone
and the friend who helped me that became
the way we said I love you to each other
um we used to say you're never alone
because that's how it all started you
know she said to me you're not alone
here
um so I think the she had the courage to
get me to open up and then I just
stepped into the safe space so if we
accept that courage was present for sure
that for sure
and that's very Noble on people I think
the reason I'm asking that is because
for anyone listening to this salmon I
I'm interested in you articulating what
are the benefits of being prepared to
ask these questions that are often on
that go unanswered yeah I mean you know
human beings are
despite our own self opinions we're not
that strong and we're not that smart but
in teams and groups we're amazing
and so trying to solve your own life
problems by yourself
I've got it so I've got some really bad
news you can't which is why addiction
exists because I can't solve these
problems myself I can't overcome the
stress myself so I'm gonna drink
you know or I'm going to do something
else that's harmful to myself my family
and my relationships as all addictions
are whether you're addicted to your cell
phone addicted to alcohol addicted to
drugs you're going to destroy your
relationships you're going to destroy
yourself
um and there is tremendous value
and it does take courage you're right
for somebody who loves you to say
I got you
I'm here
let's do this together or for you to
call a friend and say I I think I'm
struggling and
and I think I can't do this alone can
you help me it's humiliating but it is
perhaps the single greatest lesson that
any human being can learn which is to
say I don't know and I need help
um and if you can learn that
um and you can do it in the worst of
times you can do it all the time you can
do it with silly things and I I for me I
mean I mean for those who know my work
you know I regularly call myself an
idiot you know um and I do think of
myself as an idiot because I have no
problem saying I don't know can somebody
who knows who's smarter than me explain
this to me I I'm under no false illusion
that I have to present myself as the
smartest person in the room because I'm
not you know and where I'm good I might
know a sliver of something but my
goodness everything else we're talking
about I know nothing
um and
um and I think being comfortable with
asking for help and saying I don't know
um it turns out we're surrounded by
people who want to take care of us and
help us but they don't because they
didn't think we needed it because we
were too busy presenting ourselves as
perfect and having all the answers so
they just didn't but they would yeah if
we just asked
um and you know I have I have a small
group of friends where you know we
we have a deal and you know I have a
couple of friends that are super senior
super high performing
um by all traditional definitions and I
remember the first time one of us called
the other and said I'm stuck
which is really difficult to do because
you want to look smart and strong to
people who you respect and they're so
smart and strong and I have one of my
dearest friends he's in the military is
a he's a senior officer in the U.S Air
Force active duty still and uh
um I remember the first time he called
me brother
which in the military is a big deal you
know you and I have colleagues and
co-workers they have brothers and
sisters
um and so they call each other brother
and they call each other sister and it's
an amazing thing
um and I remember the first time he said
all right brother I'll talk to you later
or hey brother and I was like like that
means the relationship is different now
you know and he's a warrior I mean he's
a he's a he's he's a hardcore he's an
amazing human being and when we get off
the phone he'll say I love you you know
or he'll text me and say I miss you not
just miss you I miss you which is way
more vulnerable you know and it's deeply
human
and he and I are you know we call each
other and say I'm struggling or I'm
stuck and sometimes it's business I just
need your opinion but sometimes it's
personal
just frustration you know can I talk to
him so freaking frustrated
um but to have to Foster those
relationships those relationships take a
lot of work to get to they don't just
show up and they do require risk you
know at some point you open up a little
bit but to have those kinds of
friendships I think are absolutely
essential to being what we would call a
high performance human being I don't
think you can be a high performance by
yourself I don't think it exists
that anybody who does is it they're
either not as high performing as they
think they are or they are high
performing but a tremendous cost
um they're lonely they need pills to
start the day
um they have other issues they'll have
health issues later in life I think if
you wonder if you choose to be quote
unquote High performing by yourself it
comes at a cost that I think is not
worth it